[Applaus]
[Musik]
am 3 November 2022 überlebte im rankan
der ehemalige Premierminister von
Pakistan ein Attentat bereits Monate
zuvor im April des selben Jahres war er
nach einem Misstrauensvotum im Parlament
zurückgetreten deren solche Dinge in
einem anderen bedeutsamen Staat passiert
würde man bei uns ziemlich viel über
eine beunruhigende politische Krise
sprechen geht es dabei jedoch um
Pakistan dann ist er Achselzucken die
Folge denn solche Nachrichten sind aus
diesem Land und vielleicht nicht gerade
die Norm aber eben auch nichts
Ungewöhnliches tja Pakistan kennt
eigentlich seit seiner Gründung kaum
etwas anderes als Tohuwabohu oder
korrekter formuliert politische und
wirtschaftliche Instabilität und
vielleicht fragte euch warum wir
ausgerechnet jetzt die Lage in Pakistan
für so brisant und wichtig halten dass
wir dazu ein eigenes Video machen nur
liebe Zuschauer wir waren so alt Politik
schauen nicht nur einfach gerne hinter
die Kulissen andere Länder nein Pakistan
sollte euch aus dem folgenden drei
Gründen interessiert erstens es ist das
fünf bevölkerungsreichste Land der Welt
mit mehr 220 Millionen Menschen zum
zweiten ist es eines der wenigen Länder
der Welt das über Atomwaffen verfügt und
seine nuklear Doktrin ist gelinde gesagt
schießmütig theoretisch müsste nur
irgendein Feind auf ihr Territorium
vordringen um die Regierung in Islamabad
dazu zu bringen ihre Atombomben zu
zünden und drittens ja da waren noch
etwas anderes Terrorismus in Pakistan
gibt es alle möglichen Terrorgruppen in
vielen Fällen wurden und werden Sie
sogar vom Staat selbst unterstützt
erinnert ihr euch noch wo 2011 Osama bin
Laden liquidiert wurde genau das war ein
Pakistan und nicht in irgendeiner
einsamen Berghöhle im Hinterkopf sondern
in der Stadt aborta Bad und diese ist
Achtung einen gewagter Vergleich
sozusagen das Beverly Hills Pakistans
kann man also ein Land die Pakistan das
jeden Moment in die Luft gehen könnte
ignorieren ehrlich gesagt ist ja schon
der Gedanke beängstigend genug dass
eines der bevölkerungsreichsten Länder
der Welt das zu dem überhaupt und von
Terrorismus geplagt wird möglicherweise
kollabiert in der Tat die Lage in
Pakistan ist kr nach Jahrzehnten der
Instabilität steht das Land nun wirklich
am Rande des Zusammenbruchs und aus
welchen Gründen genau das werdet ihr am
Ende dieses Videos genau verstehen aber
wie ist Pakistan überhaupt an diesem
Punkt gekommen warum befindet es sich in
so schlimmer Lage und was hängt das Land
so sehr in seine Entwicklung heute
werden wir natürlich alle diese Fragen
beantworten und zwar wie so oft durch
einen schnellen Blick in die Geschichte
die pakistanische Büchse der Pandora
wusstet ihr das in Pakistan kein
gewählter Premierminister jemals ohne
Skandal oder Gewalt seine politische
Laufbahn beendet hat Pakistan steckt
seit seiner Gründung im Nebel der
politischen Instabilität tatsächlich war
das Attentat auch im Ranka nur ein
weiteres Ereignis in der langen
Geschichte chaotische Zustände in
Pakistan und ehrlich gesagt wenn man
bedenkt wie ist ein Amtsvorgänger so
ergangen ist dann hat er noch ziemlich
viel Glück gehabt alle anderen vor ihm
wurden entweder der Korruption
beschuldigt und landeten dann im
Gefängnis sie wurden ins Exil geschickt
oder sogar ermordet so wie die einzige
weibliche Premierministerin die das Land
hatte wenn er sehr Foto sie wurde 2007
ermordet als sie das dritte Mal für das
Amt kandidieren wollte aber lasst uns
noch mal einen Gang zurückschalten um
besser zu verstehen warum Pakistan so
ist wie es ist Pakistan wurde 1947 vom
britischen Empire unabhängig zeitgleich
mit Indien ist zuvor das Kolonialgebiet
britisch in den gebildet hatte aber das
Pakistan dass er heute auf der Karte
sieht weil ich das gleiche Pakistan das
damals unabhängig wurde
[Musik]
als Pakistan die Ketten des britischen
Imperiums abwarf bestand es aus zwei
separaten Landesteilen ostpakistan und
westpakistan dies waren die mehrheitlich
muslimischen Bereiche von britisch
Indien Westpark ist das Pakistan das
soll heute kennen aus Pakistan wurde
später zu Bangladesch schon bald nach
der Gründung kam es in dem geteilten
Schlaf zu ethnischen Spannungen die in
einen Bürgerkrieg mündeten 1971 in der
Scheidung der beiden Landesteile
resultierte 2 Jahre nach dem Ende des
Krieges verabschiedete Pakistan eine
neue Verfassung diese Verfassung erhebt
den Islam zur offiziellen Staatsreligion
obwohl sie auch sekundäre Elemente
beinhaltet
allerdings ist Pakistan weit davon
entfernt eine perfekte Demokratie zu
sein und tatsächlich hat es neben
unzähligen kleinen vor allem zwei große
Probleme seit der Sicherheit und die
Fragilität seiner politischen
Institutionen denn Tatsache ist nun mal
leider Militär und Geheimdienst
bestimmen das gesamte Funktionieren von
Staat und Gesellschaft und agieren dabei
nicht gerade zimtrecht zu ihrem Aufgaben
gehört logischerweise die Sicherheit ist
Landes aber ihre Strategie gegen den
ewigen Feind Indien ist ziemlich
drastisch tatsächlich kaufte die
pakistanische Armee selbst Sie auf den
Namen Indien mit tausend Schnitten
ausbluten lassen und worin besteht diese
Strategie nun ganz einfach Aufständische
ausbilden und Indien destabilisieren
daher ist es nicht verwunderlich dass
wir auch Nachrichten die diese stoßen
Pakistan bildete militante
untergrundgruppen für den Kampf gegen
Indien in Kaschmir ausgibt ehemalige
pakistanische Präsidentschaft in einem
Interview mit dem Spiegel zu denkt jetzt
aber nicht dass er diese Gruppen nur
finanziert um Indien zu destabilisieren
sieht mal was extreme Ministerin selbst
gesagt hat die pakistanische Armee hat
al-Qaida und all diese Idioten für den
Kampf in Afghanistan ausgebildet im
raten kann okay aber selbst die
pakistanische Führung leugnet nicht dass
die terroristische Gruppen finanziert
hat und was glaubt ihr wer jetzt damit
den meisten Ärger hat Bingo Pakistan
selbst
[Musik]
wie ihr seht gibt es in Pakistan jede
Menge aktive Terrorgruppen die immer
wieder Städte und Dörfer angreifen nicht
einmal die Hauptstadt Islamabad wird
dabei verschont und als ob das noch
nicht genug wäre mussten die armen
Bürger des Landes bis heute enorm
instabile Regierungen ertragen
Staatsstreiche wie 1977 oder 1999
hemmungslose Korruption die Ermordung
von Politiker kurz gesagt dieses
Staatswesen ähnelt weniger einem System
als eine Odyssey und jetzt ratet mal wem
sie das alles zu verdanken haben genau
auch ihre Armee denn die pakistanische
Armee betrachtet ist als ihre Aufgabe
Ministerpräsidenten abzusetzen also
installiert und das oft mit Hilfe von
Richter jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
warum die Armee so schrecklich daran
interessiert ist die Politik zu lenken
nun aus einem ganz simplen Grund um
ihren wirtschaftlichen Interessen zu
schützen das Militär besitzt direkt mehr
als 50 Großunternehmen und es wird
vermutet dass es über Stiftungen
tausende weitere Unternehmen unter
seiner Kontrolle hat insgesamt ist das
pakistanische Militär Berichten zufolge
den Geschäft in Wert von mehr als 20
Milliarden Dollar beteiligt und dabei
handelt es sich nicht um irgendwelche
Klitschen sondern Unternehmen die fast
alle in ihren Branchen den Inlandsmarkt
beherrschen wie zum Beispiel den
Getreidehandel den Markt verdüngemittel
oder den Vertrieb von Erdgas ihr könnt
Euch sicher ausmalen dass die Generäle
nicht zögern einen Regierungschef der
Korruption zu beschuldigen sobald sie
ihre Interessen in Gefahr sehen
es ist auch nachvollziehbar dass in
einem Land mit so viel politischer
Instabilität lausiger Sicherheitslage
und wichtigen Unternehmen die nur dafür
da sind für das Militär Geld zu
verdienen der wirtschaftliche Niedergang
vorprogrammiert ist wenn wir dann noch
bedenken dass Pakistan kaum etwas
exporttaugliches produziert außer
Textilien und vielleicht noch Mangos
Pflanzenöle und Lastwagen dann haben wir
das Dilemma schon ziemlich gut Begriffen
die Handelsbilanz ist in der Tat lausig
schaut sie euch an von den drei großen
Ländern des indischen Subkontinents ist
Pakistan das Schlusslicht was den Anteil
Exporte anbieten angeht dies ist ein
Indikator für seine geringe Offenheit
gegenüber der Außenwelt und die geringe
wette das Fähigkeit seiner Unternehmen
aber wenn das nun das ganze Ausmaß der
pakistanischen Probleme wäre bräuchten
wir dieses Video nicht zu machen nein es
kommt noch viel viel dicker bleibt dran
erst gerade an
Pakistans bester Freund
stellt euch mal vor ihr wollt euer Haus
mit Solarzellen ausstatten habt aber
kein Geld dafür was würdet ihr also tun
und wahrscheinlich würdet ihr euch um
einen Kredit bemühen nicht wahr im
Prinzip hat Pakistan dasselbe getan
allerdings hat der Start damit statt
Investitionen zu finanzieren laufende
Ausgaben gedeckt und zwar weil er
staatliche Dienstleistungen erbringen
wollte aber dafür eben kein Geld hatte
weil seine Wirtschaft nicht genug
hereinbringt pakistan hat sich also hoch
verschuldet aber um unser Beispiel
wieder aufzunehmen statt der langfristig
rentalen Solarzellen auf dem Dach wurden
mit dem krediteinkäufe ins Supermarkt
finanziert und den Kühlschrank voll zu
halten die Schulden des Landes belaufen
sich auf knapp 70% seines
Bruttoinlandsprodukts und ich kann mir
vorstellen was ist denkt ach komm 70 %
sind nicht dramatisch hoch vergleiche
das doch mal mit Ländern die Spanien mit
seinen 120%. okay der Punkt geht an euch
aber es gibt halt den Unterschied dass
die pakistanischen Wirtschaft längst
nicht so hoch entwickelt ist dass ihr
ein solches Verschuldungsniveau tragen
könnte das politische Risiko die
fehlenden öffentlichen Einnahmen und all
die beschriebene Probleme dafür sorgen
deshalb dafür dass erstens die Nachfrage
nach pakistanischen Schulden ziemlich
mau ist und zweitens dass die Zinssätze
zu denen das Land Finanzierungen bekommt
deutlich höher liegen und wenn wir jetzt
all diese Faktoren zusammenlegen also
weniger verfügbares Geld zu hören
Zinssätzen an werden auch 70% zu einem
echten Problem Anleihen aus Pakistan
Finanzmetropole Karachi werden sogar als
Ramsch eingestuft da stellt sich
natürlich gleich die Frage wer ist so
verrückt Pakistan noch Geld zu leihen
nun abgesehen vom Internationalen
Währungsfonds der Weltbank ist es
Pakistans bester Freund na kommt ihr
drauf wer das ist die Antwort lautet
China
das asiatische Riesenreich ist Pakistans
Hauptgläubiger Pakistan war nämlich
eines der ersten Länder das Rot China
1951 anerkannte denn beide hatten und
haben immer noch einen gemeinsamen
Widersacher Indien als 1962 ein
Grenzkrieg zwischen Indien und China
ausbrach begann die beiden Ländern
militärisch zu kooperieren in den
letzten Jahren gingen fast 40% der
Waffenexperte Chinas nach Pakistan in
den 1990er Jahren wurde diese
Zusammenarbeit auf den wirtschaftlichen
Sektor ausgeweitet und 2015 haben beide
Länder vereinbart einen
wirtschaftskorrektur einzurichten
und ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
warum sollte ich China so sehr daran
interessiert sein mit einem Landhandel
zu treiben dass ich selbst kaum
versorgen kann nur die Erklärung bringt
ein Blick auf folgende Karte
was ihr hier seht ist er von China
gebaute Hafen war da das China ein
hafenprojekt der Welt weit investiert
ist ja nichts Neues die Freie Hansestadt
Hamburg lässt grüßen aber dieser Hafen
an Pakistans Küste könnte irgendwann
Chinas Lebensader werden warum und wieso
nun schaut euch diese Karte an China
kaufte reichlich Erdöl im arabischen
Raum dieses Öl wird Tankschiffe
transportiert und passiert dabei Indien
Küsten und Indien die Vereinigten
Staaten oder einer ihrer Verbündeten
könnten diesen Transit jederzeit
blockieren es würde dazu ausreichend
diese drei auf der Karte markierten mehr
Engel zu schließen um den gesamten
Öltransporten nach China zu stoppen und
dadurch die chinesische wirtschaftlich
so strangulieren wenn diese Schiffe
jedoch bereits im Pakistan gelöscht
werden und das Öl dann auf dem Landweg
weiter nach China transportiert wurde
Rechte ist Indien oder den USA weit
weniger diese Schifffahrtsrouten zu
blockieren okay wir verstehen also dass
dies durch China attraktiv sein könnte
aber was hat nun Pakistan davon nun mal
Daumen 62 Milliarden Dollar für den Bau
von Infrastrukturprojekten wenn Pakistan
eine Produkt Wirtschaft aufbauen will
braucht es Hefen Bahnlinien und Straßen
doch nur wenige dürfen sich trauen das
Geld für den Bau solcher Dinge bei der
Regierung in Islamabad auf den Tisch zu
legen der Grund dafür ist das
schreckenswort Terrorismus
Pakistan wird von terroristischen
Gruppen richtig geplant alkaida Italy
Bahn verschiedene separatistengruppen es
ist eine endlose Liste und das bedeutet
dass setzt China Probleme hat wenn es
hier einen Hafen bauen will ein Beispiel
aus den Nachrichten
26 April 2022 Pakistan chinesische
Staatsbürger unter den vier Toten bei
Explosion in Karachi es ist schon recht
bezeichnet dass China vorgeschlagen hat
den gesamten Hafen von Quadrat
abzuliegeln um ihn vor terroristischen
Gruppen zu schützen all das erklärt
warum die Kredite aus China hörensätze
haben als die des IWF während
3% erhebt verlangsamt 6,5 %. also fast
immer kurz zusammen Pakistan ist extrem
unproduktiv wird als den Zustand dort
enorme Risiken und hat gleichzeitig hohe
Schulden beim IWF und bei den Chinesen
ein anderer Faktor der auf diesem Globus
schnell mal für ein Land entscheidend
werden kann ist die Frage wie es mit den
Vereinigten Staaten zurechtkommt nun
sagen wir mal der Beziehungsstatus ist
kompliziert
[Musik]
auf der einen Seite sind die USA der
wichtigste Markt für pakistanische
Produkte für das Wenige was Pakistan
exportiert ist angesammelt wichtigste
Abnehmer an der politischen Front sind
die Beziehungen jedoch nicht so toll
während des Kalten Krieges war Pakistan
noch ein Verbündeter gegen die
Sowjetunion bildete Washington dort
Aufständische Gruppen aus die in
Afghanistan gegen die Service kämpfen
sollten doch alles änderte sich als
Pakistan seine Atomprogramm startete
über Nacht stoppte das Weiße Haus alle
Waffenlieferungen an Islamabad aber der
größte streitpunkt ist Zweifel los der
Terrorismus Pakistan ist Zufluchtsort
für viele Terrorgruppen der schönste
Beweis dafür war eben Osama bin Laden
der globale über Terrorist versteckte
sich in einer netten Wohngegend am Rande
von roboterbad sein Haus lag nur etwas
mehr als einen Kilometer vor der
pakistanischen Militärakademie entfernt
sie waren also praktisch Nachbarn aber
natürlich will niemand etwas davon
gewusst haben mehr noch bevor die US
Spezialkräfte bin Laden hausstürmten
mussten sie ja erstmal in den
pakistanischen Luftraum eindringen das
hat der pakistanischen Regierung das
überhaupt nicht gefallen aber das ist
eher ein Thema für ein anderes Video
heute wollen wir uns ja auf die Krise im
Land selbst konzentrieren wie schon
gesagt stecken die Pakistani schon
länger bis Oberkante Unterlippe in
Schulden mehr noch sie wollen die
Schulden die sie bereits haben
zurückzahlen und zwar mit noch mehr
Schulden ihr könnt euch also vorstellen
das ist das perfekte Drehbuch für einen
ökonomischen Katastrophen will denn nun
braucht es vielleicht nur noch ein
einziges unvorhergesehenes Ereignis und
das ganze Land zum Kollabieren zu
bringen und wie wir alle wissen waren
die letzten Jahre voller sollte
Überraschungen lasst sie uns also nun
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen
[Musik]
die große Enttäuschung
habt ihr die Videos gesehen die wir der
Energiekrise in Europa gewidmet haben
dann erinnert ihr euch sicher wie
Europas Motto im Sommer und Herbst 2022
lautete wir sind bereit jeden Preis zu
zahlen um unsere Gastanks zu füllen das
würde dazu dass viele lng-schiffe die
für Asien bestimmt waren umtreten und
nach Europa fuhren wo viel mehr für die
Ladung heraussprachen cooler Zug das
waren gute Nachrichten für Europa aber
es gab dabei auch klare verliere die
asiatischen Staaten denen jetzt das Gas
ausgeht und wer ist einer der größten
Verlierer dieser Krise tja schon wieder
Pakistan in den letzten vier Jahren hat
Pakistan einige politische und
wirtschaftliche Veränderung durchgemacht
die großen politischen Parteien die
Volkspartei und die pakistanische
Muslime Liga sehen ihre Vorherrschaft in
Gefahr
[Musik]
zu eurer Info die Volkspartei ist die
Partei die Pakistan am längsten regiert
hat wenn wir einen groben Vergleich
anstellen könnten wir sagen dass sie
einer westlichen sozialdemokratischen
Partei am nächsten kommt die muslimische
Liga hingegen wäre das Äquivalent einer
konservativen Partei
doch 2018 tauchte ein klassischer
politischer Außenseiter auf der die zwei
Parteienlandschaft aufbrechen sollte
jeder Typ eines charismatischen
Anführers der auf Wahlkampftour wahre
Wunder verspricht in diesem Fall ging es
um einen cricketstar und Cricket ist
schließlich der Nationalsport Pakistans
die Rede ist von im Rahmen kam die
Partei von Iran kann trat bei den Wahlen
2018 mit dem Versprechen an die
Wirtschaft zu stärken und einen
Wohlfahrtstaat im Rahmen eines
islamischen Sozialismus aufzubauen und
da die beiden großen Parteien des Landes
von Korruption verfressen waren bot sich
die günstige Gelegenheit noch dazu mit
antikorruptions Parolen anzutreten auf
diese Weise gewann Karl am Ende während
seiner Präsidentschaft war ihnen das
Glück dann aber nicht mehr so Holz kurz
nach seinem Sieg musste er sich seine
ersten Krise Stellen der corona-krise
über alle wissen hat die corona-krise
die gesamte Weltwirtschaft massiv
ausgebremst und Pakistan sollte keine
Ausnahme sein da die pakistanische
Wirtschaft bereits stagnierte machte
Corona als wahr nicht leichter sie
anzuschieben wobei das war nur der
Anfang von kaans Pechsträhnen denn
ausgerechnet was ist die Haupt
Energiequelle in Pakistans Energiemix
genau wie schon angedeutet es ist Erdgas
[Musik]
allerdings hat das Land keine
grenzüberschreitenden
pipeline-anbindungen man hat mal
versucht eine Leitung aus Russland zu
verlegen und eine andere aus dem Iran
aber bis jetzt wurde keines dieser
Projekte realisiert zwar kann Pakistan
etwas mehr als die Hälfte seines
Gasverbrauchs aus eigener Förderung
decken aber den Rest muss es importieren
und wie kommt dieses Gas nach Pakistan
nun mit den ach so begehrten
flüssiggastankschiffen wobei Flüssiggas
schon mal prinzipiell teurer ist als
Pipeline Gas oder im parkistan ist Geld
gesagt er knapp bemessen landesweiter
Stromausfall stürzt Pakistan in die
Dunkelheit aber achtung diese Nachricht
stammt noch aus der Zeit vor dem Ukraine
kriegt also bevor LNG Tanker vor dem
pakistanischen Häfen abtreten und nach
Europa dampfen ihr könnt euch also
vorstellen was dieses Jahr so alles
passiert ist massive Stromausfälle
explodierende Energiepreise und
stillgelegte Fabriken das Fazit im
Rahmen kannst ganzes Wahlkampf Gerede
von einem Wohlfahrtstaat und eine
florierenden Wirtschaft erscheint im
Moment wie ein schlechter Scherz
inzwischen wollen völlig Gläubiger ihrer
Schulden beglichen sehen und Pakistan
hat seine eigene Währung abgewertet
[Musik]
wie ihr seht kostet eine US-Dollar im
Jahr 2017 noch 100 Rupien im Jahr 2022
aber mehr als doppelt so viel das
Ergebnis noch mehr Inflation für die
ohnehin geplagten Pakistanis Karls
krankes pakistan hat also die gleichen
Symptome entwickelt wie Sri Lanka vor
dem Kollaps über den wir auf diesem
Kanal bereits gesprochen haben eine hohe
Schuldenstand eine himmelhohe Inflation
ein abgewertete Währung und Mangel an
grundlegenden waren und als es
offensichtlich schien das kann nicht in
der Lage ist all die aufgehäuften
Probleme zu lösen wurde er am 10 April
2022 aus dem Amt entfernt im Unterschied
zu anderen Premierminister vor ihm wurde
er aber nicht der Korruption beschuldigt
es war schlichtweg das Parlament selbst
das eben durch ein Misstrauensvotum aus
dem Amt darf übrigens das erste Mal in
Pakistan das ein Regierungschef auf
diese Weise gefeuert wurde seitdem hat
Pakistan eine geschäftsführende
Regierung mit der die Mitte rechts
Muslime Liga an die Macht zurückgekehrt
ist sie hat bereits angekündigt dass sie
keine Neuwahlen ausrufen wird bevor
einige Reformen zu Stabilisierung des
Landes umgesetzt sind und der neue
Premier shabbas Sharif hat eine
gewaltige Aufgabe vor sich um die wir in
weiß Gott nicht beneiden zumal Pakistan
in diesem Sommer auch noch von einer
Umweltkatastrophe gerade zu biblischen
Ausmaßes heimgesucht wurde zeitweise
statt ein Drittel des Landes unter
Wasser die reiste sind Flut allerorten
mangelt es nun an sauberen Trinkwasser
Lebensmitteln und medizinischer
Versorgung so wie es aussieht bleibt
Pakistan einfach kein Problem auf dieser
Welt erspart aus diesem Grund werden wir
schon sehr bald in einem weiteren Video
tiefergehend über die Pläne der Achse
Peking Islamabad aufklären ich kann euch
versichern dass ich da einen Bezug auf
das Gleichgewicht der Mächte in Asien
zwischen Indien in China Pakistan und
den USA so einiges zusammenbaut und dass
dieser Entwicklung die bisher kaum
jemand in Medien und Politik auf dem
Radar hat eine Menge zukünftigen
Sprengstoff für den gesamten Weltfrieden
wirkt vergessen also bitte nicht das Abo
ist nicht zu verpassen und bis dahin
möchte ich die Frage wie Pakistan aus
diesem Multi Dilemma herauskommen soll
ruhig weitergeben schreibt uns eure
Meinung in die Kommentare was denkt ihr
kann die neue Regierung all diese
Probleme lösen welche Prioritäten sollte
sie eurer Meinung Nachsetzen oder wird
Pakistan so enden wie Sri Lanka und wenn
ja welche Auswirkungen hätte das eurer
Meinung nach auf die internationale
Sicherheit eine lange Liste von Fragen
die wir uns darstellen müssen und die
uns trotz der großen Distanz durchaus
auch persönlich angeht denn eines dürfen
wir trotz aller Fokussierung auf die
Wirtschaftslage nicht vergessen Pakistan
verfügt über Arsenal von Atomwaffen und
das möchte man doch nicht in den
falschen hinten sehen nicht wahr aber
wie gesagt darüber mehr in den nächsten
Video über Pakistan das Abo nicht
vergessen und bitte auch nicht das
Glöckchen falls euch dieses Video etwas
gebracht haben sollte geht uns bitte ein
Like und teils auch mit euren Freunden
natürlich freuen uns auf jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch mit uns hält dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]